yeah welcome to this video playing the
missing link again always playing the
Kings gambit interesting on yeah what am
I actually playing against that I
recommended the class earth at the d5
line taking nd5 ok let's see ok this is
some repin also an interesting sideline
let's see what happens yeah this water
whatever i should d 5 is also fine my
recommendation from them from the
repertoire series i tend to forget all
those lines so i have this 97 as a
backup variation and okay this doesn't
this doesn't look terrible yeah should I
try to keep the pawn and I think I
should yeah g5g five a g5 is actually
the idea of Queen f5 I it doesn't make
much sense otherwise ok yeah this is the
problem
hmm yeah he's probably just threatening
to him to second life form yeah
something like Bishop f4 yeah yeah and
those guys who play the Kings gambit and
I really quick with those kind of odds
about this kind of sex hmm yeah it's
probably just just great yeah cannot
really cannot cannot not take it yeah
the only good thing about all this is I
have a clear idea how to win the game I
member piece up but I have also a clear
idea how I could lose the game getting
getting checkmated quickly this can
really happen happen quickly him came
each from I don't I didn't fear so much
I thought that Luke age form could have
been a useful resource not a move that
he could play right away but I was more
thinking of Knight f6 and queen bee
three attacking age seven but it's it's
dangerous anyway I'm not saying I'm out
of the woods here not at all but down I
didn't expect this kind of attacking
plan check
yeah maybe just night h5 dressing the
Queen yeah the good thing is I hey I
only have her I have very little choice
and maybe I could have taken me five
actually this would have been an idea
secondly the Queen for a couple of
pieces but yeah Queen age six i don't i
don't see what what he's doing now can
you can take you take f7 and check yeah
but this at least gets get some some of
more pieces into play rook f6 I've Queen
III check
my idea is a quick 97 group g8 trying to
get some attack myself check
I don't know this makes dangerous
impression I mean for all four wide mmm
look Raquin here may be attacking edge
form and maybe getting Bishop g4
maybe you can play Queen to you one yeah
stupid
yeah this was stupid I think I was an
excellent shape before I know I'm not
sure at all I don't want to this was not
planned oh it's not exchanging Queens
cool
so who's here it's very very rare
decision why not exchange Quincy em now
okay maybe I'm just misjudging all this
terribly it's possible it's after all
rather complicated okay so I need to
take a guess
yeah you did the mind into play but
Knight f6 is not on
okay let's it's just secure secure the
d5 bishop for the time being it's not so
easy for him to coordinate chess pieces
geforce t4g finals no
I can just take it play tonight if
eighth grade okay try to use the pin
from Knight f6 okay
check attending Knight f6 2g form yeah i
probably have misplayed it but very very
difficult yeah now I'm attacking the
rook and Nyjah form this dangerous to
put it mildly
yeah I'm just winning now a very very
tricky game just take it
check
check not sure why you went into the
discovered tick check
white resins who this was very tricky
John no idea what was going on I let the
Sea Kings gambit yeah the computer is
very cool it just says blankets flat and
winning yeah I tend to believe that but
it's still it's still very very
dangerous or tricky to play okay here
queen age six winning yeah I have
overlooked Queenie one this is the
problem I thought Queenie for would be
excellent attacking this one but this is
just better this keeps on now Queen
chief four wins twin g4s a flat-out win
why why actually I probably still has
this these ideas get minus five computer
says and now but okay the King's gambit
this kind of positions are so so even I
rational so trying to make some
positional news it's okay this is good
for right now yeah but this again is
winning for black how better for black
yeah it's just a super complicated
technical position you just need your
yeah outwit your opponents somehow
that's very difficult to to judge by by
computer terms you cannot play a
technically perfect game as a human with
real time okay thanks for watching